hi and welcome back I'll take you
through this lesson on data analytics
overview in this lesson you'll learn the
steps in the analytic process the skills
and tools required the challenges that
you'll face in the data analytics
process the exploratory data analysis or
EDA technique data visualization
techniques and the use of hypothesis
testing to analyze data today we have
access to a lot of data but unless we
know what to do with it it won't be of
any help to us let's take an example of
a fictional bank statement to understand
this a bank statement usually lists
every single transaction either a
deposit or a withdrawal
along with the balance amount left in
the account as shown here though the
statement is highly descriptive and is a
good source of information it doesn't
show you the spending or saving patterns
of the user but the moment you present
the same data as a line chart you can
easily spot the overall transaction
pattern if you compare this pattern over
a period of three months you can also
spot if there is a shift from the
regular pattern here you can see that
there is an unusual spike in the
spinning pattern of the user between the
24th and 26th of April this kind of data
analysis is what alerts banks to
instances of identity theft or fraud for
e-commerce websites analyzing buying
patterns of users can help them
understand what kind of customers are
more likely to buy a certain type of
product this is how data analysis makes
your data work for you
a bank statement is an example of a
highly structured data set most data
sets that you would have to work with
will not be so structured you will have
to clean it up before you could use it
in any constructive way that's why data
analytics involves a combination of
processes to help you extract
information from these data sets along
with domain knowledge you'll need
programming mathematical and statistical
skills to arrive at a decision making
process with the help of data data
analytics is a step-by-step process to
reach a conclusion let's look at these
steps briefly the first step in the
process is to ask questions to identify
the business problem the next step is
data acquisition or collecting datasets
related to the business problem or
question from the real world
the third step comprises data wrangling
with data tools and modern technologies
that include a data cleansing and data
manipulation the next step is
exploratory data analysis or EDA with
mathematical or graphical output to aid
data analysis
data exploration is the next step that
discovers data and identifies patterns
in data
the next step is to draw conclusions and
make predictions by creating training
models for machine learning this step
uses a lot of mathematical or
statistical functions
the last step is communication or data
visualization to present the analysis
work let's now look at each step in
detail
the process of analytics mostly begins
with questions or business problems of
stakeholders here are a few examples of
questions who are my customers
why are my sales going down how do I
manage my inventory
why is my system not scaling up with
increasing traffic volume such business
problems usually trigger the need to
analyze data and answer the questions
raised this leads us to the next step to
answer the question or to address the
business problem raised in step one the
next step is for you to gather or
collect data this process is known as
data acquisition the main task is to
collect relevant data associated with
the problem the data could be residing
elsewhere a data scientist has to use
database skills to fetch the data from
databases expertise with file handling
and ability to deal with different file
formats is an important skill to
download and analyze the data web
scraping is a popular way to extract
information from the web a lot of
information sites provide streaming
api's such as twitter facebook linkedin
and other major social media and
information companies the server logs
can also be extracted from enterprise
system servers to analyze the
application performance and optimize the
overall process
data wrangling and exploration is one of
the most important phases of the data
analytics process this phase includes
data cleansing data manipulation data
discovery and data pattern
identification usually data is neither
in the expected format nor is it
consistent the data cleansing process
gets rid of unwanted elements present in
the data data manipulation techniques
such as transform merge aggregates group
by and reshape transform the data and
make it available for exploratory data
analysis data exploration uses all the
available data and presents it in either
a numerical or graphical format this
helps to identify the right patterns in
the data the data and the underlying
pattern are fed into appropriate machine
learning models leading directly to the
prediction and conclusion phase data
wrangling by far is the most challenging
phase and consumes 70% of the data
scientist time let's look at some of the
reasons that caused these challenges
unexpected data format a format that is
new and inconsistent data creates more
preparation work erroneous data data
contains lots of errors and unwanted
values that have to be cleansed
manipulate and prepare data manipulate
volumous data using data wrangling
techniques and tools and make it ready
for analysis understand structure of
data understanding how the data is
organized in the first place
linear or cluster plot them if possible
determine relationship of variables
observation feature and response are
keys and relationship between them must
be determined it's difficult to
determine this relationship choose
appropriate models model selection is
based on the overall data analysis
process to draw conclusions and make
accurate predictions selections should
be accurate or it will lead to a lot of
iterations and a waste of time
identifying the right patterns and
applying the right algorithm is critical
the hypothesis building and hypothesis
testing process together lead to
appropriate model selection mathematical
and statistical functions have to be
carefully built for the model chosen
there are some popular graphical
techniques used to depict data histogram
is very popular the purpose of a
histogram or bins is to graphically
summarize the distribution of a
univariate data set
it shows the center or location of data
the spread or scale of data the skewness
of data the presence of outliers the
presence of multiple modes in the data
another popular technique is scatter
plot a scatter plot represents
relationships between two variables a
scatter plot can answer these questions
visually our variables x and y related
our variables x and y linearly related
our variables x and y non linearly
related this change in variation of Y
depend on X are there outliers
hypothesis is used in research and
analytics to understand the relationship
between dependent and independent
variables hypothesis building can begin
in the data exploration stage but it
becomes more mature and perfect in the
conclusion and predict phase hypotheses
are testable explanations of a problem
or observation formulating a hypothesis
is used for both quantitative and
qualitative analysis to address a
research problem hypotheses that suggest
a casual relationship involve at least
one independent and dependent variable
in other words one variable which is
presumed to affect the other
for example holiday season in the year
increases traffic and purchases on the
website an independent variable is one
whose value is manipulated by the
researcher or data scientist a dependent
variable is a variable whose values are
presumed to change as a result of the
changes in the independent variable
let's now look at hypothesis building
using feature engineering
hypothesis building a way to design
models and predict the unknown can be
done using feature engineering and this
includes identifying meaningful features
based on data domain knowledge
automatically constructing new features
from the raw data based on domain
expertise constructing new features
manually from raw data based on domain
expertise
hypothesis building using a model has
three phases the first phase is model
building which comprises identifying the
best input variables for the model
judging if the model can predict the
outcome for the given input the second
phase is model evaluation it's a phase
in which you train and test the model
changing different parameters used in
the model aiming for accuracy this is
also the phase where the performance is
optimized for the following model
accuracy model performance model
comparisons the third phase is model
deployment in this phase you have
finished selecting the model you will
use to solve the business problem the
output of the model will help you take
better decisions through model
prediction model matching or actual
outcome meets the expectations
population is a large data set and
samples are a part of it a sample drawn
from a population should have all the
main attributes or features which
represents the characteristics of the
population an ideal sample can be
treated as the population itself and the
hypothesis outcome for a sample would
hold true for the entire population in
the example displayed here two samples
are drawn from the population of a large
data set each sample has a mean the
process of calculating the difference
between the means is known as hypothesis
testing two kinds of hypothesis can be
made initially alternative hypothesis
this hypothesis indicates that the
proposed model outcome is accurate and
fits the data there is a difference
between sample data s1 and s2 null
hypothesis this hypothesis is the
logical opposite of the alternative
hypothesis and does not support the
proposed model it suggests that there is
no difference between sample s1 and s2
the process of hypothesis testing begins
by dividing a big data set into training
and test data sets irrespective of the
size of the data set this is one of the
best techniques to design an accurate
model the training data set is used to
build a new proposed model it makes use
of the available features and responses
of the data sample the test data set is
used to test the proposed model the test
data set acts as new unseen data the
null hypothesis that was formulated will
be proven right when the proposed model
does not predict better than the
existing model the alternative
hypothesis will be proven right if the
proposed model predicts better than the
existing model typically the training
data set size is anywhere between 60 and
80% of the big data set and the test
data set ranges between 20 and 40
percent of the big data set
the last step is communication where
they analyze the data is formally
presented to stakeholders the use of
several data visualization techniques
make the communication effective data
analysis can be presented in various
forms such as visual graphs plotting
maps creating reports writing a white
paper or even through a PowerPoint
presentation
data visualization techniques are used
for a graphical representation of data
and are powerful tools for effective
communication following are the main
benefits of data visualization
simplifies complex quantitative
information identifies the relationship
between data points and variables
identifies patterns in data establishes
trends present in the data and guides
the analysis process here are some
examples where data visualization can be
applied if you want to present
information about new and existing
customers and their behavior when they
access your website if you want to see
web traffic patterns for the website for
example more activity on the website in
the morning than in the evening let's
now look at plotting another effective
data visualization technique plotting is
a data visualization technique used to
represent underlying data through
graphics this is used often in data
analytics it can be understood as a
coordinate system like x-axis and y-axis
that represent variables and you can
mark your data based on the data set and
the mathematical equation the process of
plotting is also like telling the story
about your data through different colors
shapes and sizes you can also show the
relationship between variables through
plotting for example the value of X
changes if the value of y changes based
on this information the visual or graph
changes similarly you can show that one
variable is independent of the other
variable there are several types of
plotting techniques that can be used to
visualize data the choice of plot
depends on the kind of data you are
dealing with sometimes more than one
plot is used to develop a better
understanding of the data when there is
a new data feed or you have not worked
with such data before you can use more
than one plot following are a few high
level plot selection techniques if the
data is continuous histogram line chart
regression plot
if the data is categorical in nature or
you need to identify patterns in the
data scatter plot cluster map heat map
an important point to note is that the
data analytics process is an iterative
one this means that during every step of
the process you have to check the
original question or intent to ensure
that the analysis is on the right track
at the end of the process you should be
able to answer the question or solve the
problem through data analysis by
retracting the step scientifically
here are the skills and tools required
for each step of the data analytics
process question or business problem
ability to ask relevant questions and
understand the problem domain knowledge
or substantive expertise passionate
about data analytical approach data
acquisition beautifulsoup for web
scraping CSV or other file knowledge
numpy pandas database data wrangling CSV
or other file knowledge numpy pandas
database Sify data exploration numpy
Sify pandas matplotlib conclusions or
predictions scikit-learn the main
machine learning library CSV or other
file knowledge numpy pandas database
Sify communication or data visualization
pandas database matplotlib PPT CSV or
other file knowledge let's now look at
some of the challenges of the data
analytics process
let's now quickly recap what we've
learned in the lesson data analytics is
a process that will answer a question or
solve a business problem there are a
number of skills and tools required to
carry out data analytics successfully
the data analytics process is
challenging in the data wrangling data
exploration and the model selection
phases exploratory data analysis
includes quantitative and graphical
techniques data visualization techniques
communicate data characteristics and
patterns effectively hypothesis testing
is used in research and analytics to
understand the relationship between
dependent and independent variables this
concludes the lesson data analytics
overview the next lesson we'll discuss
statistical concepts and business
applications